[Music]
so today we canceled usa today for an
article published yesterday originally
titled what the public keeps getting
wrong about pedophilia
a link to the article was initially
posted to twitter along with a lengthy
thread explaining that pedophilia is uh
misunderstood and misrepresented
and uh but the actual article was hidden
behind a paywall a short time later the
entire thread was deleted and a new
tweet was posted explaining quote a
previous thread did not include all
information and the story it was written
about is behind a paywall we made the
decision to delete the thread
they also apparently made the decision
to change the headline of the article
which is now titled the complicated
research behind pedophilia
now it's impossible to know what other
edits they may have made but they
removed the paywall and let's read a
little bit from the article as it now
stands
quote pedophilia is viewed as among the
most horrifying social ills but
scientists who study the sexual disorder
say it is also among the most
misunderstood
when most of the public thinks of
pedophilia they assume it's synonymous
with child sexual abuse a pervasive
social problem that has exploded to
crisis levels online
researchers who study pedophilia say the
term describes an attraction not an
action and using it interchangeably with
abuse fuels misperceptions the american
psychiatric association's diagnostic
consistent manual of mental disorders
says that pedophilia is defined by quote
recurrent intense sexually arousing
fantasies sexual urges or behaviors
involving sexual activity with a
prepubescent child or children
scientists have in recent decades
improve their understanding of
pedophilia's causes prenatal and early
childhood risk factors as well as how
pedophiles can better control impulses
one of the most significant findings is
that scientists who study this disorder
say pedophilia is determined in the womb
though environmental factors may
influence whether someone acts on an
urge to abuse
all right the article then goes on to
favorably reference alan walker you may
remember walker as the creepy college
professor who advocates for
destigmatizing pedophilia walker's
affiliated with the prestasia foundation
uh which we've talked about on the show
he he's appeared on there he or she i
know i can't remember which one on their
uh youtube channel and in interviews on
their their site
this is an organization that is several
levels beyond creepy and which is also
concerned with
destigmatizing pedophilia
in fact if you go to prestigious website
right now
the very first thing that pops up is a
quote safety guide for quote age play
if you're wondering what that is
prostagia explains that age play is
quote a form of role play in which at
least one of the participants adopts the
role or mindset of someone younger a
teenager a child or even a baby
so now you have some idea of what we're
dealing with
back to the article in alan walker it
says
an academic at old dominion university
in norfolk virginia who's talked about
destigmatizing pedophilia and referred
to pedophiles as minor attracted people
resigned in november following the
outcry over the phrase alan walker
argued destigmatizing the attraction
would allow more people to seek help and
ultimately prevent child sexual abuse
there is growing support in the field
for walker's point of view while
clinical psychologist james cantor said
there's no treatment that can turn a
pedophile into a non-pedophile
pedophiles can be taught self-control in
compensatory strategies which he said is
more likely if they're under the care of
a professional he argues that pedophiles
need to be able to access therapy which
can be difficult since those afflicted
may be ashamed to seek help or worried
about being reported to the authorities
if they do
now
what can we say about all of this after
we finish vomiting into the nearest
trash can the most generous possible
interpretation is that the author and
those quoted in the piece are drawing a
distinction between impulse and action
and advocating for strategies to help
prevent pedophiles from converting those
horrific impulses into action
now that sentiment alone by itself the
idea that we want to stop pedophiles
from acting on their desires is of
course uncontroversial everyone agrees
it's so obvious that it's not a point
that really needs to be made
now it could be a worthwhile discussion
if you're presenting actual tangible
prevention strategies
but all that the author of this piece
the author's name by the way is aaliyah
destiger
has to offer is therapy
that's a rather broad and useless
suggestion especially because it
requires us to have faith in the
psychological industry to handle the
issue effectively and appropriately and
i have no such faith
and that brings us to the larger problem
although there is a nugget of truth here
that there's a difference between desire
and action
and we want to prevent the actions
again obviously we want to prevent the
actions
but the very troubling and ultimately
fatal flaw
is that the morsel of common sense is
couched in a lot of pablum about
destigmatizing pedophilia
they're treated as a valid community
an oppressed community a victim class in
their own right
and much much emphasis is placed on the
on the claim that pedophiles are are
born with this desire
now that latter point may also be true
in some cases it's possible
that something has gone wrong in the
brain of the pedophile and that at least
in some cases we can trace the problem
back to the womb
now that entirely removes the moral and
spiritual element once again
medicalizing the problem of human evil
which is a problem but um but it
wouldn't surprise me if there was some
sort of neurochemical facet to this
issue
fine
but the problem is that all of this
stuff
it's a community
they're stigmatized they're oppressed
their desires are natural quote unquote
they're born with it
all of this has always been the pretense
for eventually normalizing and then
finally celebrating the act itself
now they're not doing it yet explicitly
even the nightmarish prostatia
foundation with its guide for pedophilic
sexual role play
isn't coming out and explicitly saying
that it's normal or good to rape
children
what we're witnessing now is the
groundwork
they're digging the foundation they're
laying the bricks for the hideous
building that they plan to construct
we've seen this process play out enough
times to know where it leads in fact the
idea that people who are born with
certain sexual desires should repress
them refrain from acting on them that is
fundamentally incompatible with the
leftist worldview anyway
that's how we know that when it comes to
pedophilia normalization the current
point that we're at right now is but a
stage that they're passing through on
their way to the ultimate destination
now you might hope that this will be
different because most of the other
forms of perversion normalized by the
left have involved consenting adults of
various numbers and combinations
but children cannot consent obviously
perhaps the consent issue you might hope
will create a barrier
it will be like gandalf standing on the
bridge screaming you shall not pass this
is the one boundary that the fiery demon
of leftism cannot cross you might say
you might hope but we know that the left
is already hard at work on this issue as
well
on breaking down the idea of consent
because they tell us that children very
young children children as young as two
or three
can consent to all sorts of things
make all kinds of decisions even sexual
decisions
they can consent to change their gender
so you see how another foundation right
now is also being formed more bricks are
being laid
eventually the two construction project
projects will be connected
and within a few years i give it maybe
five years
the actual act of pedophilia will be
openly and explicitly defended
this usa today article is just one of
the opening salvos in that effort
and for that reason
usa today is today
cancel
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated